hasard du calendrier les journées du
patrimoine coïncidé cette année avec la
journée des jardins à paris 80 sites et
est ouvert au public dont de nombreux
jardins dits jardin de curé
sophie mais elle marie-christine courtès
les jardins de curé offert aux
promeneurs une fois n'est pas coutume
mais aujourd'hui pour fêter le premier
jour de l'automne
chaque parcelle de verdure de la
capitale même la plus sacrée livrer ses
secrets au public
dans l'autre partie qui est là c'était
l'ancien pensionnat de jeunes filles
portes ouvertes donc à la congrégation
des sacrés-coeurs de l'adoration de
picpus portes ouvertes encore à saint
joseph de cluny qui abrite depuis près
de 200 ans
les soeurs missionnaires ici il y avait
des doutes pêches pommes et
voir
ici
le potager a disparu faute de seurre
jardinières subsistent les arbres
fruitiers et quelques d'aliapur fleurir
l'hôtel un samu végétales des
consultations vers bobo aux gens une
initiative et ces mères qui a drainé bon
nombre de jardinot maniaque au coeur de
paris sache sur la paye bien que nos ce
ticket prescription personnaliser les
plantes vertes sont aujourd'hui presque
aussi bien traité que des animaux de
compagnie une fois par semaine
le public en redemande et pour le
satisfaire c'est une dernière parcelle
des 14 hectares du parc de bercy qui
vient tout juste d'être inauguré la
nouvelle gare notaire son potager
didactique à souhait fait le bonheur des
bout'choux et de leurs parents sont
vertes les tomates
elles sont bonnes quand elles sont
vertes manin on commence dans les plans
de tomates et on finit à la maison du
jardinage un lieu pour demander des
conseils et prendre des cours
c'est tout nouveau et c'est tous les
samedis à partir du 18 octobre